[Music]
jet is a very selfish agent a lot of
people didn't use jet originally i
remember you just dash away if you're
gonna die
actually that's basically the only
reason the character is good it was just
like she didn't exist and people just
thought she was bad
cool let's go fastener coming alive in
this one three kills looking for the ace
as easily
for the backside there's another right
click acid against the ace but now
immortals after that last one are you
choking me his tongue is real
they know they're collateral the mystic
fools they're gonna try and charge him
down here zip and they're just on the
other side oh my god
as long as you can shoot first and e
away and you you get the first kill
literally a free kill every time i
wonder like if jet didn't exist how
would the game feel today she's so sick
dude like if you're a really good jet
against people who aren't that sick just
style on them you know very waiting up
in the window
oh
that was sick
all right folks before we get into the
video i just want to let you know that
this one is brought to you by geico now
mastering all the skills you need to
become a top tier jet mane isn't easy
but you know what is switching to geico
15 minutes could save you 15 or more on
your car insurance so check out the link
in the description below for more
information
jet has been a core part of valor since
the very beginning she exemplifies
everything that makes valrant different
from other tactical fps games she moves
fast and emphasizes verticality in a way
that makes valor unique
but even though she's basically the
cornerstone of the game the community's
opinions on her can get pretty divisive
why because when valrant first came out
everyone thought jet kind of sucked
initially she was the agent that didn't
really play well with a team as war isle
pointed out during the closed beta jet
is a very selfish agent all of her
abilities benefit jet and jet alone her
smokes suck you gotta throw them by hand
like the other ones where you can pretty
much throw them through walls and across
the map and put them wherever you want
and they don't last for very long and
the rest are just movement abilities now
if jet was easy to master this lone wolf
approach could still probably benefit
any team she was on unfortunately though
if a player didn't have her mechanics
down jet could be more of a liability
than an asset as click heads explained
sure she has three smokes but they last
so short that it's hard to really get
any use out of them you have to sort of
just spam them down and rush in and hope
for the best spray and pray is generally
not the best strategy for winning in any
game and so you either devoted yourself
to jet mastered her mechanics and mained
her and her alone or you forced your
team to 4v5 without you every time you
picked her and died at the beginning of
the round
oh geez
uh well i don't know what just happened
there well i do know what happened i got
killed and since jet's abilities are so
unique seriously no other agent
invalorant does what she does switching
off of her is not easy the only thing it
does is make the individual
careless and
creates bad habits for the player where
if they try to switch off the agent they
will be really bad like noticeably bad
that's why like a lot of these one trick
jets are getting dropped because i'm
assuming it's like they build up these
habits and then they switch to a
different agent it's like wow this game
is so much harder because i can't just
dash away and in the early days of
valerian's competitive scene some pros
agreed jets saw barely any high level
play in europe for months after the game
came out but despite all the hate some
players saw jet's potential early on and
remain faithful to this day when i did
the alpha test the content creator test
i was under nda and stuff only character
i played was yet like at the very
beginning it's locking jet for me it was
movement stuff like playing cs like
everyone's on the same level even
playing field
i said chat was like kind of so crazy to
me that like i could get a free shot and
dash away i could updraft and take all
these off angles a lot of people didn't
use jet originally i remember
i think i was the
i brought a jet i remember in a beta
tournament and nobody else was running
it so and nobody else ran yet it was
just like she didn't exist and people
just thought she was bad and i ran into
the match just running
running jumping around opping people
jumping at them with a shorty so
that's pretty strong i realized that see
what the community began to realize is
the things that made jet unique actually
made her broken jet's abilities allow
her to reach and utilize angles that
other characters in the game don't even
have access to giving her a built-in
positional advantage her verticality is
perfectly suited for maps like icebox
and breeze where she can scale on and
move between objects in ways that other
characters literally can't her alt is
basically like having a free vandal in
eco rounds the knives kill on headshot
don't lose accuracy while she moves and
refill every time you get a kill and
since using the ability costs absolutely
nothing outside of alt points a jet can
skip buying a decent weapon saving
precious credits and making their team's
economy that much better for when they
need to get stuff for themselves or
their teammates next round the off
arguably the best gun in the entire game
is a perfect complement to the
aggressive push style of play the korean
agent was designed for since she can
take her shot and dash to safety
instantly in the hands of a truly
capable jet the op shines if he would
have been my friend but now immortals
after that last one are you choking me
his town's really does pull they know
they're collateral at this point he's
definitely immortals immortals
what what can they even do they make
their way on site
no
tens with an ace and when you put all
those things together you end up with
what is probably the best agent in the
game so what's the same with that one
single knife is he able to get a
headshot whether that's the question and
refresh those knives if so
there's a real opportunity here for sure
just use that one frag oh
that as well the dash comes through he's
gonna whiff doesn't matter oh gosh
shazam finds another the updraft over
the top here is he tries to find the oh
my god
he's gonna be greeted by four members of
fbx if he does opt to go for this though
can he want to get away he does again
the mystic falls they're gonna try and
charge him down here zip and he's just
on the other side oh my god
here comes the first swing there's no
trade though at all set well eventually
attempts will find it in fact he gets
boasted as well up on top of the
structure we'll see what else tents can
find here as he looms above ever
dangerous doma takes down absolutely
everybody except tense can he find him
no tens obviously when monsters like
tens play jet she can do some incredible
things but eventually even naysayers
like asuna came around and now as a part
of hundred thieves he splits his time
between jet and reina and since his team
is going to master stage three in berlin
he must be doing something right this is
but it's just overwhelming nitro here oh
asana's in the picture now with his
bladestorm trying to find the headshots
couple knives left on this one to try to
get the ring press he gets the refresh
asana keeping the round the chances
he has the wall and the molly the retake
is possible here
that's looking for another one he gets
it two more players to go asana coming
alive in this one three kills looking
for the ace as he starts
with the blade storm coming all the way
from the b side to save it keeping an
open mind about a character that is so
different from what you'd expect from a
traditional fps is important but there
are also many arguments in favor of
being a jet man jet dared to go where no
agent had gone before
literally
[Music]
and as difficult as mastering jet may be
if someone is good enough at the game to
play it for a living chances are they
can and will make even the most skill
intensive character work is jet your
worst to us it just depends if i'm
hopping or not like how good i'm feeling
today
not a
watch this omen there's just
wherever i am there's just in my uh
as far as the pro scene goes jet is a
high risk high reward agent who simply
requires some dedication to be viable
you can press e and you get away for
free you can get aggressive with a free
pick you can play defensive with the
free pick you can push over a smoke you
can do your nerdy jet things where you
buy a shotgun and you dash into u-haul
and clear a u-haul with a judge like
ultimately i think her ultimate
ultimately her ultimate is really really
powerful right now too the fact that
there's no damage falloff the really
really good jets are just super hard to
deal with casual players tend to get a
little bit more emotional when faced
with the insta-lock jet on either side
of the server
[Music]
and then there is of course riot who are
caught in the middle attempting to
balance jet without screwing up things
too badly for the pros or the casuals
she's like one of the only agents that
can make aggressive plays and get like
get out safely so it allows like
streamers and
professionals to play here and make
flashy plays so they can get content my
theory is basically she's like pretty op
right now
still even though i think this way
because like the individual is able to
carry but if the individual is not able
to carry it's kind of like awkward with
her um
and like that ride doesn't want to nerf
her basically to like the ground instead
of gutting jet's kit riot has started to
go after her economy by raising the
price of abilities and reducing the
price on guns riot is trying to push
people away from spamming abilities and
towards gunplay look jet is the face of
the hyper aggro flashy alt-reliant
playstyle that's given us some of
valoran's best moments so far but that's
exactly why riot is trying to tone her
down a little bit jet is likely to
suffer the consequences of her updraft
and cloudburst going up in price as well
as her bladestorm now requiring an extra
point to activate but that's exactly
what riot wants as pro guys explains
riot wants to tone down how
authoritative she is in game so they are
hitting her most powerful abilities with
price changes to bring down her power
level a bit that's because her smokes
and updraft were so cheap it was too
easy for her to purchase all of them
every single round whether she was
saving or full buying riot did not like
that so they upped her prices to make
jet think twice about investing in
utility on a save round but jet has been
changed before and true maine's will
always find a way to make her work and
this round of nerfs was no different as
long as ryde doesn't gut her kit jet
will continue to reign supreme they're
always like tuning her to make her like
better like on on beta jet
or um just when they buffed jet when
mater smokes seven seconds
she was really really strong through it
all despite players complaining that jet
was broken and entire regions all but
ignoring her early on she has remained
the face of valorant since day one south
korean jet mains have been doing things
that no one knew were possible and
that's exactly the point jet is supposed
to have a near infinite skill ceiling
but the spike is being defused it's
halfway done another cloud burst goes
down they're just gonna commit oh no he
actually boosts out of there this is
insane
terry waiting up in the window oh oh
oh
that was sick does he get it in time he
does
the half defuse that
that was
crazy you could say that to no jet is to
no valorant heavy nerfs might not only
take away jet's status as valran's
highlight machine and cost us plays like
the one you just saw but also defeat the
purpose of creating an agent like her in
the first place jet was never supposed
to be just another agent just like
valrant she was made to be different to
prove that there's always room to try
new things and to show all of us that
keeping an open mind really is the path
to success i feel like it's the most
entertaining character to watch as well
as most fun to play so
i think that's like super important to
the game because of that
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages